bien on va faire l'interview mensonges
du même principe doit mentir voilà c'est
pas compliqué comment ça va co et bella
écoute ça va super bien
tu es content d'être ici ce soir
franchement je me fais chier grave et ça
me saoule de talent cette séquelle âge
maintenant écoute un bon 22
ouais là les volets demain tagro aussi
un peu non d'abord ça me fait très
plaisir ce que tu me dis et non je pense
que j'ai pas mal mais grid 1 ou 2 kg 1
ouais tu dois beaucoup à bataille et
fontaine
que dalle je trouve que ce sont des gros
cons tu es fier de travailler avec eux
écoute je vomis chaque matin mais
beaucoup un jeu je suis beaucoup
beaucoup tu arriveras pas me faire dire
des saloperies que tf1 ça se passe bien
écoute on se défonce la gueule tous les
matins tous les matins on s'insulte et
avec les patrons de tf1 c'est une
affaire d'amitié avant tout non non
c'est une affaire de coucheries parce
que je suis le fils d diène et il a eu
des rapports plus haut entre nous la
méthode cauet tu trouve ça original
comme concept chez ans mais je trouve
que je t'ai tour pompe et ça c'est pas
l'interview - sans les y attend carnet
de chèques bordés d'ailleurs tu nous as
du blé pour les attirer au filet des
poutres parce que je voudrais revenir le
reste du décor est très bien vous
retrouver à la fin de l'année je te
donne une adresse à des poulets colonnes
les colonnes corinthiennes j'appelle ça
des poutres et poutrelles apathique
la bande à picsou en même temps dis moi
il ya quand même des interviews un peu
qui ressemble un peu à celle de tout le
monde en parle des fois écoute
franchement non jamais oh oui je suis
très content j'invente 1 je n'arrive
même pas à le suivre
quand tu tombes à bourgas est une ville
meilleur animateur de la course est le
dire mais je suis mauvais bond des prix
il est édenté sartine bloc les faits qui
griffent commet jamais une interview qui
ressemble aux miennes départ et tu as
remarqué que j'ai jamais fait de
scandale à toi suite envoyé une lettre
où une fois mais après j'ai abandonné
oui mais j'avais tout mis dedans tu as
oublié deux et il avait dit que je
réponds péter hauteur et qu'il y avait
des trucs dans ton émission qui était
dans la mienne voilà là c'est plutôt des
trucs dans ton émission mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas su quoi répondre et d'ailleurs
ce que je comprends bien non parce qu'on
m'a envoyé un chèque je côtoie nom n'est
pas ce que parce que d'abord tu as
peut-être paf tu as peut-être pas tort
vu que tu fais de la tna mais tant que
tu fais de la télé depuis avant moi vu
que georgette pas cité de date mais vu
que quand j'étais petit je te regarder
mais que djouhri moment que j'étais fan
jamais je ne manque plus que j'étais fan
lunettes noires pour nuits blanches que
j'aime et double je vois bien à
l'antenne on voit bien qu'on n'a pas été
nombreux à aimer mais moi j'aime et et
les zèbres
alors il ya un truc que je comprends pas
a me dit tu étais de chez daphné roulier
tu m'as pas cité une seule fois avec ta
chemise jaune pour il parce que si je
cite c'est parce que si je cite tout le
monde ça fait léger qu ado parce que
j'ai cités qui j'ai cité foucault un
tapis et admirait beaucoup déjà et à
pomper la patrie chambéry caire mais
mais
sébastien mais en plus tu sais que tu me
pique mes idées mais j'existe mais je te
piquent pas tes idées je trouve juste
que je franchement je vous jure que
c'est vrai franchement quand on fait un
hommage chaque semaine à tirer ardisson
non mais franchement subissent tous je
n'ai pas répondu à ta lettre mais je te
jure qu'on t'a rien appliquée d'accord
et je te promets que si j'enlève du
mensonge je te les rendrait ici je te
les amène je te jure d'accord fait le
studio de la méthode cauet je te prends
le pari si je viens tu as mené les
colonnes donc on enlève derrière mais
parce que moi perso j'en peux plus si
toi tu aimes bien vachement faible et
j'adore donc je te les ramène riche mais
j'ai quelles sont les émissions que tu
regardes en ce moment pas beaucoup je
dois te regarde et toi
c'est obligé en même temps non assise
pour trouver des idées non non non ouais
il paraît que tu es un grand b heures
c'est vrai écoute non et de soulever la
méthode certes en sens interdit
non mais là